so roger suggested this technique so i
said i would get to the technique he
said
the next time you find yourself
embroiled in an argument with someone
that's contentious and uncomfortable say
institute the following rule
you don't get to respond to the person's
claims until they've exhausted that
particular claim and this does presume
to some degree that you're dealing with
a good faith actor even if they feel
differently than you do you don't get to
respond
until you have
recapitulated their viewpoint and
summarized it
in a manner they find acceptable
that's so
treacherously sneaky that rule
because what it means is
you have to demonstrate that you
attended to what they say
closely enough and carefully enough
to first of all act out validation of
the idea that they have an opinion worth
attending to that's a big deal
people really like being paid attention
to there is nothing people like more
than that unless they have something to
hide and even then there's a part of
them that would rather have that paid
attention to than fail to pass what
would you say
to go unnoticed every cynic is entirely
disappointed when his or her cynicism
goes unchallenged because there's a part
of them like a little unwarped part of
their soul that's still alive thinking
oh my god i hope someone calls me on all
my foolishness and cynicism because if
they don't that means that it's valid
and generally applicable and and i'm in
hell and what good is that
and so and i really mean that i really
mean that and so
so you're called upon to first of all
summarize what they said which is not an
easy thing right because it means you
have to sometimes it's somewhat
incoherent and emotional laden
especially if it's in the course of an
argument so you have to sort of strike
right to the quick it sounds to me
like this is the point you were making
and then you lay out the point and then
you see they have to be happy with your
summary they have to be pleased with it
which means that you're doing exactly
the opposite of straw manning the
argument quite the contrary and you're
doing them a favor in some sense by
reducing it to the gist because that's
actually an incredibly complex cognitive
operation i had one client
who was extraordinarily seriously
affected and in the final analysis i
don't know if i was of any help to her
because
the
the pit of family pathology she was in
sconston was so deep that no matter how
far we dug there was already always a
number a new layer of lies underneath
the lies we had already worked months to
uncover it was just awful like homicidal
level awful literally terrible
but she told me
she went on a tangent
that lasted
for four consecutive day clinical
sessions like they weren't the whole day
but they were
50 minutes on four consecutive days i
had no idea where she was going she was
wandering all over in this freudian
associational manner
and she came to the point at the end of
it it was unbelievable she tied together
this she was very intelligent woman she
tied together this tremendously long
incoherent ramble into a little bow
right at the end like the punchline of a
remarkable joke and so
and she had extracted in some sense the
gist of what she was saying as a
consequence of the circumambulation the
wandering through all this territory and
when you listen to someone very very
carefully and especially if they express
themselves for a while and you say to
them well it sounds to me like this is
what you're saying what you're doing is
taking
a tremendous amount of emotionally laden
material a lot of it
unnecessary in the final analysis
because of the ensuing synthesis and
offering them a synthesis which is a
great thing to do
especially if they're happy to accept it
because that also means that you did
listen to them so you signified that
they were worth attending to and then
you listened to them enough to actually
understand what they were saying to try
to understand it and then you did
understand it and then they're way
happier with you even if you're arguing
with them because at least now they know
they can rely on you to be a reliable
listener and that you're not trying to
you know how it is when you're arguing
with someone there's a party that really
wants to win it's like i'm right
you're stupid and wrong
and so the best way for me to
demonstrate that is to warp and bend
your argument in some make it trivial in
some way it isn't especially if it's
directed to some degree it's like
elucidating my character flaw flaws and
and to minimize you in doing so and if
you do that of course well that's not a
great road to peace unless you're
willing to bring a big club to the
argument and and many people are and
instead of listening and trying to make
peace and sort things out they'll use
all sorts of subtle forms of suppression
in their ensuing dialogue just to keep
everything you know under the rug or in
the closet i wouldn't recommend that as
a medium to long-term strategy
especially if you're trying to bring
peace to a household you have to go
through this horribly painful process of
listening to the people around you tell
you what they think of their lives and
if you do that then well maybe you can
all come to a place that is
characterized by something approximating
genuine peace and i would say that even
psychophysiologically you know i mean
when there's tension in a household in
multiple
what would you say systems of value
operating simultaneously there's a
tremendous confusion about what should
reign supreme right and you think well
nothing has to reign supreme we can all
have our diverse opinions it's
no you can't not if you're going to live
together in harmony there has to be some
overarching structure that unites you if
there i mean what what else is a family
if it's not an overarching structure
that unites you now within that there
can be tolerance and even appreciation
for necessary individual differences and
obviously there should be but that
doesn't mean there's a not a higher
unity that the entire
organization let's say is striving for
in some manner and not only striving for
but pining for or even dying for and i i
don't use those words lightly like the
absence of that incorporating higher
structures is a felt sense of
catastrophe on the part of the members
of the family they're always at each
other's throats they're interfering with
each other's goals they can't listen
they're in a chronic state of hyper
arousal because they don't know what to
do ever they're hopeless because no
goals have been clearly defined and we
experience almost all our hope in
relationship to defined goals so this
isn't some what would you say humanity's
myth or some some reality that isn't as
concrete as everything that you see
before you it's quite the contrary and
as far as rogers was concerned
well you had to let people talk
to find out what they thought
so they could find out what they thought
so they could move towards something so
they could move away from hell
because that's certainly what you see in
clinical practice i mean people are
suffering in ways you can hardly well
you can probably imagine because no
doubt many of you have either been there
or seen people who were there lived with
them
you know to move away from that is
that's more real than anything else if
pain is more real than anything else
what's even more real than pain is
whatever we have to fight off the pain
and that's free speech
it's identical with freedom of thought
it's associated with this capacity and
necessity to listen deeply they're flip
sides of the same coin to use a terrible
cliche
and all the clinical data we have
including the more stringently
researched research oriented clinical
inquiry indicates quite clearly that the
ex the exchange of information like that
the generation of of of semantic and
emotional information in a state of
relative freedom the revelation of those
thoughts and then the discursive
analysis of those thoughts say and then
the implementation into action and the
testing of them that is the pathway to
health insofar as that can be attained
by say psychological or spiritual means
and so that's why free speech is not
just another
freedom or right among many
it's certainly not viewpoint diversity
or anything like that it's the it's the
mechanism by which we generate the
conceptions that allow us to organize
our experience in the world it's that
mechanism and more than that it's the
mechanism that allows us
to
reformulate and criticize those
conceptions when they become outdated
and sterile to dissolve them into a
chaos that we have to contend with while
it's occurring and then to reanimate
them in a new form so that we can move
into the future
and so if you're concerned with the
oppressed let's say why in the world
would you oppose free speech it's the
only thing the oppressed have
and if you don't understand that i would
say well that's either an ignorance
that's so deep that you should remediate
it as rapidly as possible or a
malevolence that's so appalling that you
should face it even though you'll face
it at your peril
and so you can't come to a university
like this that's been a bastion of free
speech in a country that's been a
bastion of free speech and a light unto
the world in that regard for
a thousand years and all do credit to
all of you for that
it's like don't forget this
this is the fundamental thing
say the entire judeo-christian
enterprise
to this date has been an attempt in some
sense to elevate to the highest place
the notion of the divine redemptive word
and there's no truth that's deeper than
that and that's that
so
thank you very much
you